Now that you've entered the presidential race and started raising money,...
...how can you tell if you are succeeding?
One way is through polls, which measure public opinion.
Polling data is collected in part by...
...phone calls, online surveys and social media traffic.
But what determines whether a candidate will do well in the polls?
One way to gain support is through televised debates.
Depending on how well candidates express their views on topics...
...such as the economy, foreign policy and social issues,...
...their poll numbers will go up or down.
Some candidates may not be popular in every area of the US,...
...which means they'll have to travel to strategic locations across the country...
...to strengthen their poll numbers.
If they're successful, all that campaigning will result in improved popularity...
...and positive media coverage.
And if they're not, they may not make it to the next stage...
...when voters actually begin the election process,...
...during the primaries and caucuses that are held in each state.